[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
- this see the world DRI
thank you so much when I was four years
old my dad taught me the Taos Pueblo
hoop dance traditional dance born
hundreds of years ago in southwestern
USA a series of Hoops are constructed
out of Willow Wood and they're used to
create formations of the natural world
showing the many beauties of life in the
dance you're circling in a constant spin
mimicking the movement of the Sun and
the passage of time watching this dance
was magic to me like with the time
capsule I was taking a look through a
cultural window to the past I felt a
deeper connection to how my ancestors
looked at the world around them and
since then I've always been obsessed
with time capsules they come in many
forms but the common thread is that they
hold a portal to a memory and they hold
the important power of keeping stories
alive as a filmmaker and composer it's
been my journey to find my voice reclaim
the stories of my heritage and the past
and infuse them together into music film
and virtual reality time capsules to
share but first I want to share a bit
about how I grew up in Southern
California I was raised in a
multi-generational home meaning I lived
under the same roof as my parents aunts
uncles and grandparents on my mother's
side she's Dutch Indonesian and Chinese
with immigrant parents and my father is
Ojibwe and an enrolled tribal member of
the pray band Potawatomi tribe in
northeastern Kansas so one weekend I'd
be learning how to fold dumplings and
the next weekend I'd be powwow dancing
traditional style immersed in the
powerful heart beats of drums and
singers so being surrounded by so many
cultures was the norm for me but it was
a really confusing experience I it was
hard for me to find my own voice because
I never felt I was ever enough I was
never Chinese enough never Dutch
Indonesian or native enough and because
I never felt like I was a part of any
singular community I sought to learn the
stories behind my heritage and connect
them together to rediscover my own and
the first medium I felt gave me
voice was music with layers of sounds
and multiple instruments I could create
sound scapes and worlds that were much
bigger than my own and this right here
is actually the setup that I have in my
room this instrument here is one of my
favorites to play it's the Chinese Gong
zither and I learned how to play it from
online tutorials and another thing I
learned was that while the hoop dance is
hundreds of years old that Chinese good
songs are there has over 2,000 years of
history and I noticed an interesting
connection the zither is tuned to the
pentatonic scale which is a scale found
so universally without within the world
and I noticed that native folk songs
also carry with it the pentatonic scale
and in both Chinese and native folk I
sense the sound of yearning and longing
for the past and this is the sound that
deeply inspires the music I create today
and at the time I wondered if I could
make this feeling of immersion even more
powerful by layering images and visuals
over the music so I went back to online
tutorials to learn editing software and
went to community college to save money
and created films after a couple years
of experimenting I was 17 and I had
something I wanted to tell and preserve
and it started with a question what
happens when a story is forgotten I lead
with this in my latest documentary film
smoke that travels which invites you
into a world of song and dance as I
explore my fear that a part of my
heritage will be forgotten in time as of
right now there are so many indigenous
languages dying due to historically
forced assimilation from the late 1800s
to the early 1970s natives were forced
into boarding schools where they were
violently punished if they practiced
traditional ways or spoke their native
language most of which were orally
passed down right now there are 567
federally recognized tribes in the
United States when there used to be
countless more in my father's words the
native is not about the braids or the
feathers and the beadwork being native
is all about how we center ourselves in
the world as human beings after
traveling with this film for over a year
I met indigenous people from around the
world from the I knew of Japan and the
sami of scandinavia and many more who
all were dealing with this exact same
struggle to preserve their language and
culture and I want to tell a quick story
around that same time I finished my
first ever tiny experiment with
rotoscoping an animation technique I
traced over 112 frames from a video of a
beautiful fancy shawl dancer named
Danielle Bayer and this is how it looked
so I posted this online very tiny video
not expecting anything just wanting to
share it with my friends and family and
the next morning and expectedly I woke
up to hundreds and thousands of views
and comments saying oh man I want to
bring my shawl back out and go back to
the powwow or oh I miss dancing I want
to I want to get back out there again
and the most striking comment to me was
someone who said I've never seen a fancy
shawl dancer animated before ever and
prior to this it never even occurred to
me that there aren't many traditional
style dancers in animated form they just
don't exist and at this moment I not
only realized the power storytelling has
to connect all of us as human beings but
the responsibility that comes with this
power it becomes incredibly dangerous
when our stories are rewritten or
ignored because when we are denied
identity we become invisible and this
concept is so important to me with new
rising mediums like virtual reality in a
medium so powerful where you could
surround yourself and step into a new
world and immerse yourself into these
new perspectives it's so important that
we have our identities and stories
existing within them in the
foundational era right now and it's also
important for the creators themselves to
be empowered to make these experiences
just for the joy of storytelling right
now I'm exploring a young VR video game
programmers cyberpunk musical adventure
set in Tokyo Japan and I'm dreaming up
this world in virtual reality room scale
a diary
filled with a treasure trove of objects
from a favorite toy to an old family
trinket 3d scanned in from the real
world and when you pick up that object
you could hear the very story behind it
just like a time capsule again like a
window to the past and I I'm more
fascinated with creating alternative
realities that let us draw parallels to
our own rather than recreating the real
world because all around us here were
all we're all mixed mixed backgrounds
mixed cultures different hometowns and
whether we know it or not whether we're
aware of it or not we have so many
stories and events in our lives and our
histories that make up who we are today
and we're all storytellers perhaps
reclaiming our narratives and just
listening to each other's can create a
portal that can transcend time itself
[Applause]